Speaker 1: I want to start today with a story that
several of you sent me about a black democratic
leader who threatened, who was threatened
with lynching for criticizing the former
President Donald Trump. Let's go right to the
New York Times article. Iowa Democratic chair
says he received lynching threat after criticizing
Trump Ross Wilburn, the first black person to
lead Iowa's Democratic Party, said he received
several racist messages after writing a column
in the Des Moines Register. Iowa's
Democratic Party chair said on Tuesday
he received a lynching threat and several other
racist phone and email messages after he wrote a
column in the state's largest newspaper denouncing
former President Donald Trump and Republicans.
The party chairman Ross Wilburn, the first black
person to lead the Democratic Party in Iowa,
the presidential proving ground, said that he
turned the messages over to the police in Ames,
Iowa, and planned to press charges if the
people who sent the messages were identified.
Speaking to reporters over Zoom, Mr. Wilburn,
a state representative from Ames, said that
the threatening messages were in response to an
October 8th opinion article that he wrote in the
Des Moines Register titled Iowa Republicans Put
Loyalty to Trump over helping Iowans. The columns
publication preceded Trump's rally in Iowa, his
first visit since losing in 2020 and since the
Jan. six insurrection, Wilburn said Tuesday.
At some point, we have to say enough is enough.
We can't control thoughts that people filled with
hate have. But when you speak out, when you choose
to act in certain ways, that's when it's not
OK. On October 8th, Wilburn said he received a
voicemail from a restricted number, ending with
a threat that included a reference to lynching.
Over the next two days, he said, racial slurs were
repeatedly directed at him. In another voicemail
and an email sent to his legislative account,
Commander Jason Tuttle of Ames Police Department
said in an email that Wilburn filed the police
report and police were investigating. You know,
one of the things. There's so many layers to the
the speech rights that the right likes to claim.
It's not shocking that the pro-Trump people, when
they got angry with a black guy for criticizing
Trump, they said racist things. To him, that's
not a shock. That's kind of like blasé in a sense,
sadly. But but it is at this point we've become
very, very used to it. You know, they really
have this confounding, convoluted understanding
of speech when it comes to, as we talked about
yesterday, the right being angry that stories they
want to see in the mainstream don't get enough
attention because they're dumb stories. They say
that it's suppression of speech. Now, of course,
media outlets and people can choose, I want to
talk about this or I don't want to talk about that
is not necessarily an indication of suppression
of speech or censorship or self-censorship. Some
stories are just kind of dumb. Then when there
are consequences to their speech, they say, Well,
that's a restriction of my freedom of speech.
No, you were allowed to speak and say what you
wanted about the election results or about lab
leak or Hunter Biden or whatever. But also,
there are reactions to your speech by people who
themselves have the right to speak as well, but
they don't like that, that that's not good. But
then here, instead of this just being a reaction,
a consequence to the speech of Mr. Wilburn, they
actually go over the line because threatening
people with a lynching or with personal injury or
calling them and leaving repeated racial slurs.
Those may be the consequences to Wilburn speech,
but that goes beyond into criminality because
those are now threats and it's harassment.
So like on every level on this speech thing,
enforcing terms of service is not a First
Amendment violation. It's not even the government.
It's a private company enforcing their terms of
service reaction to the thing I said. Well, now
my speech is being suppressed by that speech. No,
it's just the consequence of your speech. And as
long as it's not illegal, threatening or otherwise
against the law, it's just something you have to
deal with when you speak. People might react to
that. OK, well, then I'm going to react to what
Wilburn said by threatening with a lynching. No,
that actually is a crime. At this point in time.
It's a continued and persistent misunderstanding
of every aspect of what free speech, censorship
and the ability to say what you want to say in
media outlets to cover what they want to cover.
They misunderstand all of it at every
single level, obviously, in the case of
Mr. Wilburn. Let's hope they actually find the
people who made those horrible racist threats.